♪ OUT
>> SIT DOWN EVERYBODY.
SIT DOWN.
THAT LADY FAINTED, GET HER SOME
WATER.
IT'S BEEN ANOTHER GREAT WEEK OF
SHOWS THINGS TO WAIT, BUT MOSTL
DUE TO ME.
HAD TO WAIT DO THIS EVERY DAY?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AND
FRANKLY IT'S NONE OF YOUR
BUSINESS.
YOU'RE REALLY VERY NOSY.
USUALLY THIS IS WHERE I WANT
EVERYONE INTO THE WEEKEND WITH
ANOTHER THOUGHT-PROVOKING
MONOLOGUE, BUT TONIGHT WE'RE
CHANGING THINGS UP.
ON FRIDAYS WE TYPICALLY DO OUR
LEFTOVER SEGMENT AT THE END OF
THE SHOW, NOT ANYMORE.
>> GREG'S LEFTOVERS.
>> IT FEELS LIKE THE END OF THE
SHOW.
IT IS TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR
LEFTOVERS, THE SEGMENT
DOCUMENTARY SAID THE THING
PROVES GREG INTO STAFF NEED
PROFESSIONAL HELP.
IT'S WHERE I READ THE JOKES WE
DID DIDN'T READ THIS WEEK.
HE ALWAYS GIVES ME A THUMBS UP
DURING PROSTATE EXAMS.
HOST OF DR. THROUGH.
SHE TALKS BUSINESS LIKE IT'S
NOBODY'S BUSINESS, LIZ Mc
DONNELL
>> TOMORROW IS HER BIRTHDAY, SH
DOESN'T LOOK A DAY OVER 50.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
THE GOODYEAR BLIMP AS HIS BILL
WILL.
THE NWA WORLD TELEVISION
CHAMPION TYRUS!
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DIG IN AS THEY SAY.
AS ALWAYS IT'S MY FIRST TIME
READING THESE SO IF THEY SUCK,
DON'T BLAME ME.
THE COFOUNDER OF RED BULL WHO
CLAIMED TO DRINK A DOZEN CANS O
THE BEVERAGE PER DAY DIED THIS
WEEK AT AGE 78.
THE FAMILY PLANS OF PRIVATE
BURIAL ONCE HE STOPS MOVING.
>> ONE OF ONE, EVERYBODY.
THE GOLDEN ROBES AIMED
RESTAURANT SET TO OPEN A NEW
YORK CITY NEXT MONTH REDFIN SLI
FORWARD TO THE DINNER SPECIAL
SCHEDULED FOR 3:00 P.M.
SAW THAT ONE COMING.
>> OTHER THAN THAT IT'S LIKE AN
OTHER RESTAURANT EXCEPT THE
WAITRESSES CONSTANTLY ASK YOU
WHY YOU AREN'T MARRIED YET.
DURING A RECENT TV APPEARANCE
MARTHA STEWART SAID SHE WOULD
CONSIDER MARY DEEDING PETE
DAVISON.
SHE SAYS HIS TATTOOS REMIND HER
OF HER PRISON GIRLFRIEND.
DURING AN EPISODE, PRESIDENT
BIDEN DROVE A CORVETTE 118 MILE
PER HOUR IN A DRAG RACE.
WHEN ASKED BY REPORTERS WHAT WA
LIKE TO GO THAT FAST THE
PRESIDENT REPLIED PANCAKES.
I LOVE PANCAKES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS MOCKED THIS
WEEK FOR CLAIMING THE EXTRA COS
OF AIRLINE SEATS IS UNFAIR TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
RIGHTFULLY SO BECAUSE IF ANYONE
IS COMPLAINING ABOUT NEEDING AN
EXTRA SIX ENGINES IT'S PROBABLY
NOT THE BLACK GUYS.
CUTS ADDED, WHILE THEY'RE HERE
THEY MAY AS WELL VOTE.
>> IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
I JUST CLAIMED THAT.
NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE, DID YOU
?
A NEW STUDY FINDS THAT ONLY
ABOUT 5 PERCENT OF PLASTIC IN
THE U.S. IS RECYCLED EVERY YEAR.
THERE GOES MY CHANCES OF
WHIPPING FOREVER SAID MADONNA.
THAT WAS GOOD.
SPEAKING OF, SHE'S DEBUTING IT
YOU HAVE NECKLACES THAT HAVE A
TINY TOY ATTACHED RATE FOR
JEWELRY IS AVAILABLE IN GOLD OR
SILVER AND ACCORDING TO THE
FORMER SINGER PAIRS WELL WITH
HER LIFE ALERT BRACELET.
>> THEY JUST COULD'VE SAID LIFE
ALERT BRACELET AND THEY WOULD'V
GOTTEN A GOOD LAUGH RIGHT THE
CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
OWN FUNERAL AND EXPERIENCE BEING
.
ALIVE FOR $57,000 FOR IT YOU
DON'T NEED THAT MUCH TO EXTREME
BEING RIGHT ALIVE YOU JUST NEED
50 BUCKS FOR A HOTEL ROOM AND 5
BUCKS FOR A 400-POUND.
ACCORDING TO HUNTER BIDEN.
>> I DIDN'T LIKE THAT ONE.
SPIRIT AIRLINES OFFICIALLY
APPROVED TAKEOVER BY JETBLUE IN
RETURN SHAREHOLDERS WERE GET A
BAG OF BLUE POTATO CHIPS AND A
CASE OF RINGWORM.
A NEW LABOR DEPARTMENT REFORM
FINDS THAT INFLATION HAS DRIVEN
HALLOWEEN CASSIE KINNEY PRICES
TO HIT RECORD HIGHS FREIGHT
ISSUES TRICK-OR-TREATERS WILL
HAVE TO SETTLE FOR GENERIC RAZO
BLADES.
THIS WEEK POPE FRANCIS SAID EVE
NUNS HAVE PROBLEMS WITH WATCHING
.
ACCORDING TO THEIR SEARCH
HISTORY THE FAVORITE POSITION T
WATCH IS MISSIONARY.
IT FELT GROSS COMING OUT OF MY
MOUTH.
USUALLY IS THE REVERSE.
>> IRON PLAYING YOUR GAME.
A FLORIDA MARIJUANA COMPANY
BEING SAVED AFTER COMPLAINS THA
THEIR WEED WASN'T MAKING
CUSTOMER SIGN-UP FOR THE COMPAN
REFUTES HIS FAME SEEING THE
PRODUCT SEEMS TO BE WORKING JUS
FINE FOR JOHN FETTERMAN.
AND, FINALLY PROGRESSIVES ARE
LAUNCHING A NEW PLAN TO
RADICALIZE REAL HOUSEWIVES BY
LITERALLY SOCIAL MEDIA WITH
LEFT-WING PLATITUDES.
WE WANT TO COMBINE OF KNOX'S
WOMEN IN POLITICS JUST TURN ON
THE VIEW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> I WOULD GIVE THAT A SOLID B+.
TO THE BIG STORY OF THE DAY.
THE ELON TWITTER PURCHASE IS
OFFICIAL.
NO ONE NO SOONER THAN HE THAT H
SENT EXECS TO OUTERSPACE RATE I
$44 BILLION TAKEOVER IS A DONE
DEAL.
NOW HE CAN FINALLY ADMIT MAN
HAVE A.
THIS IS PRETTY EXCITING.
I LEGITIMATELY THINK HE IS GOIN
TO DO SOMETHING BIG FOR IT.
>> HE'S ALREADY STARTED.
HE CAST OUT A BUNCH OF
EXECUTIVES RATE I'M CONFUSED BY
WHY PEOPLE ARE UPSET WITH HIM.
EVERYTHING HE TOUCHES GET BETTER
.
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND, HE
WALKED IN WITH THE KITCHEN SINK
FRED HE DOES THAT MEAN HE'S
GOING TO THROW EVERYTHING OUT,
BUT THE KITCHEN SINK, OR WHAT
WAS HE EXPECTING THE MESSAGE.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT TO, HE'S
THROWING AWAY EVERYTHING BUT TH
KITCHEN SINK.
WHEN HE WAS GOING FOR WAS LET
THAT SINK IN WHEN YOU'RE A
BILLIONAIRE, NOBODY'S GOING TO
ARGUE WITH YOUR INJURED TEAM.
>> HE SHOULD PURPOSELY DO REALL
BAD PROP COMEDY.
>> HIGHER CARROT TOP.
>> THAT'S HOW CARROT TOP RULES.
>> HE'S GOT NO FRIENDS.
MY FAVORITE CARROT TOP IS LIZ M
cDONNELL.
>> KNEW HIS RED LEGS HEAT NOT
EVEN HUED RED, REALLY.
>> IT'S RED.
>> OKAY, IT COULD BE THE DRUG
SPREAD DID HE SPENT TOO MUCH ON
TWITTER?
>> YES.
I WAS WONDERING ABOUT THE WIND
BUSINESS MODEL.
THIS BUSINESS MODEL BEING MS.
CHAIN HATHAWAY OF BEVERLY
HILLBILLIES TELLING EVERYBODY
WHAT TO THINK RIGHT IT'S LIKE
HAVING THEM FLOAT UP AND ONE
OVERSEEING A BUSINESS IN THEN
CENSORING WHAT PEOPLE THINK, BU
OH ALLOWING THE DICTATORS, ICE
IS DOING BATTLE PLANS FOR THIS
IS YOUR BUSINESS MODEL?
MAY BE THE KITCHEN SINK WAS
GOING TO TOSS ALL OF THAT OUT
WITH IT.
THIS IS THE WAY YOU WENT, NOT A
GOOD IDEA.
>> YOU THINK IT WAS A BAD MOVE?
GIG I THINK WHAT HE'S GOING TO
DO IS MAKE A I THINK HE'S GOING
TO HAVE CHINA SHOPPING ON IT
TEXTING ON DOING ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
BUT HE'S GOING TO TAKE IT IN A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
NOT JUST TRYING TO BE THIS
TOWNSQUARE WHICH SILICON VALLEY
TURNED IT INTO.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
>> AREN'T YOU THE LEAST BIT
CURIOUS?
>> DON'T SAY IT WAS A WEE WEE
CHECKED CHAPPED BREATH.
>> IT WAS THE DR. IN HIM THAT
MADE HIM CURIOUS.
YOU WANT TO PUT ME IN A 48 HOUR
HOLD, DON'T YOU?
>> KAT, WHAT DO YOU WANT HIM TO
CHANGE ABOUT TWITTER?
>> FOR ME TO HAVE MORE FOLLOWERS
.
>> OBVIOUSLY IT IS SKEWED.
THERE IS ONE SIDE WHERE THINGS
GET BANNED IN THE OTHER SIDE
DOESN'T.
I'M ALSO SOMEBODY WHO LIFE IS
THE SAME ALL THE TIME.
ANYTHING THAT WILL SHAKE IT UP
LITTLE BIT IS ALWAYS KIND OF
GOOD.
>> ISN'T IT GREAT THAT HE FIRED
THE LADY WHO WAS IN CHARGE OF
KEY KICKING PEOPLE OFF OF
TWITTER BRICKEY OF COURSE HE DI
PRETTY GOOD NOW IS TRIM GOING T
COME BACK ON?
HE SAYS NOW.
BUT I MEAN, THE WAY TO FIX ANY
FREE SPEECH IS VERY DON'T HAVE
AMERICA'S BABYSITTER SITTING IN
SILICON VALLEY TELLING US WHAT
TO SAY.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY
EXPLANATIONS OF WHAT IT DOESN'T
WORK.
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP, OR THE
LAB LEAK THEORY, THEY WERE WRON
AND THEN THE WRONG AGAIN AND
THEY CHANGE NOTHING IT SEEMS TH
SAME IN THERE.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE EAT THINK
YOU'RE A JERK WHEN YOU HAVE TEN
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON THE
LINE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO US
THAT JUST TO BE A JERK, YOU'RE
GOING TO USE THAT TO MAKE A GOO
INVESTMENT.
>> WE ARE MISSING THE BIGGER
POINT.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING AS THE
EXTINCTION OF THE WOKE CULTURE.
IT WAS THOSE PEOPLE WHO DECIDED
HE WAS CANCELED, IT WAS NOT.
IF SOMEBODY TWEETED SOMETHING
AND WANTED TO SUPPORT IT THAT
PERSON WOULD GET 1 MILLION LIKE
AND 1 MILLION RETWEETS.
THE CEO WOULD SAY MY GOD, THAT
IS A MOVEMENT.
IF YOU HAVEN'T CHECKED YOUR
FOLLOWERS, THE DAY HE SHOWED UP
MY TEMP TO 30,000, SO I'M NOT
EVEN A GUY WHO GOES IN SIZE
RIGHT WING STUFF I DON'T BELIEV
IN CONSPIRACIES, IT'S LIKE WORK
OUT, WATCH A SHOW, COME TO MY
SHOW, WATCH OUT, WORKOUT, HANG
OUT WITH MY KIDS.
THAT'S IT.
>> THAT IS RADICAL RIGHT WING
PROPAGANDA.
>> THE PEOPLE LEAVING THE BAR
LEFT OUR LEAVING TWITTER SAYING
WE ARE LEAVING.
>> I HOPE THEY MOVED TO CANADA.
>> YOU WATCH HOW IT CHANGES.
YOU WATCH, BECAUSE THE
CONTROLLER, SHE KICKED HIM IN
THE AND PUT HIM OUT.
>> INVESTORS HAD.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THE AVERAGE
TWITTER USER IS LIKE?
IT'S LIKE A PERSON WHO FOUNDS
OTHER SPICE HAS BEEN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT FAMILY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THERE GOING TO DROP ALL THE
CENSORSHIP AND STATE YOU MEAN
I'VE ONLY BEEN GETTING THIS KIN
OF INFORMATION AND NOW I'M
GETTING ALL THIS INFORMATION
IT'S LIKE FINDING OUT THAT
THERE'S BEEN A WHOLE SECRET LIFE
.
>> IT'S LIKE BEING IN MSNBC
VIEWER.
>> EXACTLY.
>> BUT BETTER LOOKING.
>> I HAVE LOOKED AT THAT METRIC
IN THEIR VIEWERS ARE HIDEOUS.
>> YOU'RE VIEWERS ARE GOOD.
>> THAT IS APPEAL.
TO ME, THIS IS OBVIOUSLY OUR
FIRST TOPLESS FRIDAY, BUT WE
CAN'T SHOW YOU AT HOME, BUT IT'
DEFINITELY DISTRACTING.
ESPECIALLY THE SISTERS UP THER